hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am here with the
cast and showrunner creator executive
producer i don't know all the titles you
have i'll stop there of resident alien
and i'm saying hi to everyone there too
off camera i like doing that um
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming in today i really appreciate it
thank you for having us we were really
excited to clear up the
you know the news yeah
we're glad to finally get to say our
side of this yes exactly
addressing the allegations
i want to start with congratulations on
getting another season
right
which is fantastic
um
is this pardon me for not knowing is
this your first time doing comic con as
a cast
yes
this one the new york comic con in 2019
i think before the pilot yeah before we
even aired right so it's a completely
different beast now because people now
understand the show they know who you
all are the characters all that stuff
yes there's like a pop-up thing here
there's aliens there's more than one
alien running around down there i was on
an elevator actually with two aliens and
with their people and they couldn't see
and they were being like you know it was
very funny
i i found it amusing and i'm like oh
they they're spending a little money
they have aliens they brought the cast
i'm like they're you know what i mean
yeah so i i love learning about like the
behind the scenes the making of a show
so for all of you guys for fans of this
series what would they like be surprised
to learn about the making of the show
what goes on behind the scenes we all
hate each other
oh the snow's real and i i can't stand
anyone i work with yeah i just don't
like them a lot the snow isn't always
real
see it's this type of thing i have to
deal with
we uh every season we've gone up to the
top of a glacier
uh up in whistler and we get to take uh
helicopters up and it's always a bit of
a crap shoot you don't know whether or
not you're gonna get to go up because
weather can change very fast up there
and so they write it hoping we can do it
they schedule the time and then we sit
there and go can we and one day we
couldn't yeah
and one day we could we have to take a
very small group of people up there so
in the first half of season two when we
went up there we couldn't take any hair
and make up people so it ended up being
uh alice and i ended up being
alice and sarah
doing hair and makeup on alan and his
crafting which was fantastic yeah and we
made a little crafty sled
yeah
so it's it yeah it's a little it's a
little it's it's fun it's a little
slapdash at times we're up in vancouver
things are done a little bit differently
um but we're a big happy family um what
ellen i said that we're a happy family
up in vancouver with our canadian
brothers and sisters
liz is canadian they do do things a
little bit differently right sometimes i
feel like doing a show in canada
it's better to
think of it like we're doing a show not
to commercial in italy because you'll be
like
these crazy italians they do things so
differently because canadians going keep
going
canadians do you think our crew's
watching this
[Laughter]
somebody wants this i don't think they
can
what one of the things that i enjoy
about the show is that all of you guys
have moments to shine in basically every
episode and if there's some fun it can
be serious and fun and kooky that it
goes all over the place can you sort of
talk about how much are you guys finding
in the moment and adjusting and like
preparing alts for what i can tell
already that you don't look at the
script
i'm joking i'm joking
no because no because exactly because
she's naturally very funny
yes
uh how much is it sort of like you know
the script version versus allowing to do
alts and finding fun moments because you
guys all bring something you know what i
mean levi
oh me oh oh that's too many mics uh i
would say i mean chris uh you know
writes i mean there's a writing team but
chris is always on uh on set with us and
kind of the policy is you know we get
one as written so we have it and then
he's usually very gracious about letting
us you know play around or improvise
which i mean this entire cast is like
except for me uh knows how to how to
improvise but it's you know you just
kind of take that ride with uh yeah
wherever it's going yeah we kind of like
like you said do one pass where it's
like what's on the page and make sure we
got that for if that's as an option and
then
it's sometimes you find these little
moments that are birthed from someone
else trying something that
creates something for someone else and
then and then liz wants to say something
no because levi was pressing the mic
okay so and this is how it goes allow
and and i would say that
uh chris and everybody on the show the
directors included like really allow us
to and not just allow but rely on us i
think to cr to take care of our
characters you know like alan is
um in touch with
who
harry is because he helped create harry
right so everything you're in the shot
just up a little bit and um going and
we'll go from the top and everybody has
to be aware of where their story is at
especially when we're blocked shooting
and who they are in that moment like
what is darcy going through what's and
so we are kind of responsible for
uh keeping everything true to so
sometimes scripts come out and there'll
be a thing here or there and it'll be
like yeah it doesn't feel like she's
thinking about that at this point and
we'll work with it on the on the day
which hopefully doesn't happen and chris
is like please don't do this on the day
but they do it you know they were and
it's always it's always to take care of
the story and i i've found that it i
don't know it's really gratifying
yeah it is incredibly helpful from it
from our standpoint
sorry no i'm being earnest
no i think it is incredible it is
incredibly helpful because there's only
so much we can keep track of but they
are uh the shepherds with their own
characters so so they'll come in and say
this doesn't feel right and you have to
listen to that and we'll talk through it
and they're never wrong they feel very
you know very close to their characters
and um and it helps the adjustments uh
you know on the day or ideally a couple
days before sometimes they'll come in as
we're starting shooting saying this
doesn't work for me and i'm like didn't
get the script last week
and they say well yeah about my computer
i had problems and
not everyone um pointing at me there's
uh
most everyone is respectful
you know what's fun working with all of
you amazing comedians i love seeing
who's gonna get the last word you know
like when we're all together yeah
because i don't it's not me i'm not the
one i get to be the straight man
reacting to all of you but i feel like
you all one up each other on set i think
corey and liz always have a little bit
of a battle yeah
every time we're improvising we're
always trying to get the last word in
every time every single time all the
time every single time signs
right here that's how we do it and scene
and we just you know that's our style
and you're fired
one of the things about the last few
episodes of the second season that that
have aired is that the last one ends
with what could be opening the door to
someone else learning about harry and
also we are introduced to an alien baby
and i'm just curious how much do those
things play into
uh the new episodes that are coming soon
big big big big time big lots yeah i
think the rest of the season involves
those two those two things it was a good
place to cut it off for that reason
uh
let's not get started on that
so now we're gonna finish with that
there's a dead body you saw she killed
somebody he
almost saw he almost saw but i'm in
route you but that's all that's coming
up we don't know oh right but no that
was teased in the the premiere of the
trailer
yeah
right yeah and yeah and then there's a
baby on the loose well harry is more
than groggru yeah harry is from aries
found out that there's a goo
that that there's a new alien race on
earth but doesn't know much about him
because he's getting the message from
the baby and the baby got scared off so
now harry's got to find this alien baby
to get the rest of the message as we go
into the second part of the scene
so there is more alien baby in the
second half of the season which is that
baby yoda
when did you guys finish filming the
second season actually are you still
filming no we finished first week of
april this year okay so we're still in
post for another four or five weeks i
think we have a shoot that's happening
in like an hour right something like
that yeah there we're done so obviously
you guys got picked up for another
season
how much
how much when you i guess where when do
you start filming the next season and
are you even thinking about are you guys
writing like where are you in that
process well we just got picked up so as
of a few days ago when we got picked up
yes we're starting to start trying to
figure out what season three is now
season second half of season two comes
out august 10th um we do eight more
episodes and i can't really say right
now what's in store for season three
because it's dependent on where season
two ends which is insane so there's a
lot of incredible stuff in the second
half of the season and it builds to an
incredible place and there's a lot of
shooting off points for the church and
and
we can't tell you we can't tell you
what that word means
but we might say that in the second half
of the season there may be that those
two words in there what are you doing
better than grow
something i'm curious about is for for
the cast uh in every um what are the
scenes when you see the script that
you're
like oh my god i can't wait to do that
and what are the scenes when you see the
script you're like [ __ ] this
like i am dreading this is going to be a
tough day
well i know i can say for me
one of this oh i can't say what the
scene is there's a scene coming up
where i get to do more funny stuff with
you and another character who we can't
say yes uh we haven't met yet
the days you know you get to just like
almost just pure comedy days like you
don't have to worry about a drama or
like emoting so much those days are
really fun um the uh when we did uh
episode six the really heavy stuff on
the best on the bench that was it was
very gratifying at the end of the day
but it was very nerve-wracking and we
were both very stressed out so those are
the days where you're like oh
boy there's a lot riding on
moments you know there's a lot riding on
that storytelling in that moment in
particular and um
you want to make sure that you're able
to not only deliver a performance that
you're going to be happy with that that
you can walk away from feeling like okay
i left it all on the table you know what
i'm saying but at the same time one
that's going to service the storytelling
in a way that's going to best benefit
the show as well so yeah you know no
pressure
i can't that was a needle to thread that
was that was
that scene it really was because it's
it's a comedy and it has dramatic a lot
of drama and it's an hour-long show and
there aren't a lot of shows that do it
because it's it's not easy to do and
yeah that can make you cry for different
reasons and i think that's something
unique to our show i was gonna say the
opposite like i look forward to a
dramatic day going in and out because
you're
but then i had to talk to chris about
like how does asta make a joke like once
we got to a place where she was a little
bit lighter and dancing around and like
what is what's funny to her and how does
she how is she funny i found a moment
where i felt like i was being sort of
like mayor ben one day and i was like
how dare you
i was just like i told chris how do i
how do i do this how do i who what is it
takes a lot of jokes around skills yeah
i think it's different for different not
everyone can do it
yeah so anyways interesting i love you i
love you now that we're not there i
can't think of anything that i'm ever
looking at the script and going like i'm
not
and the only thing that i see when we
get this like the call sheet for the
next day as i look right at the weather
because
vancouver can have some bad weather and
i remember one time i looked at a call
sheet and for the weather report it just
said it's vancouver
they're like okay all right so that can
be it but otherwise i love filming
everything on this show alice is often i
just call her and say i just call alice
sometimes and say do you mind uh flying
in a helicopter scene
so we have to dangle you out of a
helicopter are you okay with this or do
we have to get a stunt person and before
you can finish the sentence she's like
yeah so he calls me now and he's like
would you mind yes i'll be there what
time
because it's just
yeah i get to operate a forklift i get
to all sorts of stuff yeah
so
what about you
i like i like it
i'm into it you know whatever the stuff
is i like yeah i like the physical
comedy you know whenever we do those
things
i don't know i'm there a lot
i'm into it
i i really enjoyed your scene where you
are eating your friend the octopus oh
yeah
like i really i really enjoyed that
scene it was because it's you could see
like you were emotional about it but it
was also delicious yeah it was it was
very good it's tough it's tough when
that happens uh
yeah that was a lot of fun it was a you
know nathan fillion uh doing the voice
of the octopus at 42
was very nice and it was a it was a
really good hero's ending do you see
that the boys copied us
literally
oh he had sex with the octopus no he had
an octopus friend that he ended up
eating all right little nod to resident
alien on the boys on amazon prime don't
don't worry i love it
[Laughter]
don't oh i wasn't gonna say after don't
right mike real fast cause i'm out of
time but we're at comic-con i wanna do
this really quick if you were able to
walk on the convention floor what is the
thing that you'd be obsessing over or
buying like what would you be going
after real quick uh at the uh brown
coats uh california brown coats booth
they have a bunch of stuff uh that i
gave them that they're
auctioning off you can buy a raffle
ticket and the money goes to charity wow
so that
yeah
i'd be looking for rare unique like
action figures if i found a resident
alien sheriff mike action figure it
would change my life so if it's out
there someone changed my life
i'd be looking for a bra with aliens on
it thank you for two microphones thank
you
i would also say the brown coats booth
because it the money is going to charity
and the charity is kylie jenner's jet so
you should
it's it's
it's for native american first nations
uh in canada and then also in brazil
so that's the one brown code's booth my
truthful answer was going to be alph
merch but now i feel like i can't say
that i need something more
responsible
well you could give the alpha merch too
i like the donation thing merch as well
the brown coats booth is that right yes
okay so do that what is wrong with you
for me probably uh searching for a
resident alien merch that is sort of
illegally created yeah
so he can get his [ __ ] cut
that's right chris is very litigious
on that note i want to give a huge thank
you to you guys for coming by i wish
that's the emergency sound
i'm just gonna say thank you guys so
much for coming by i'm really really
happy for the success of the show for
all of you i hope it's on for a really
long time thank you so much